[Music]
don't know if i can whistle more that
song
okay there we go hey you folks hope
everyone's doing well this evening hello
carowind
that other ted
their alt trekkie
homebody gozer aaron crystal
hey angus
don't know if i'd ever do that right
miss wicked wolf
herbie john karasu getting everybody's
getting in on this
glad to see folks here
tara madison cora will oh time traveling
waffle
do you have time traveling maple syrup
to go with that that's my only question
i'm actually not a huge fan of waffles
oh cappuccino
well i don't see now you're just all
saying hi see if i'll do everybody uh
nick and crochet tiger renee
nevermore
hollow coffin i think i've gotten
everybody did i say franklin hi franklin
all right that's it i'm not doing it as
more people come in but there you go
um
i'm a page 121 i need to finish soon
because it's morning in germany and i
need to continue writing
i i understand the push to
uh to get
to get to your writing yeah i get that
um
oh thank you homebody thank you very
much
um
i don't wear this dress often this is a
wrap dress which
is the only one i have and i do like it
i just always feel like i'm about to
fall out of it
which like depending on my mood can
almost be like a ooh but then you know
when i'm broadcasting on a platform that
i could get banned off of if it falls
off me then it's a bit like
okay
my mom has been looking at a
christian film review site that's very
anti-anime and now i'm panicking
oh god is that on the is anime still
like on the
religious conservative hit list
i remember that being an issue when i
was a kid in the 90s basically for the
same reason that friggin
south park was like it's animated but
it's not always for kids and sometimes
it's adult content yes because elsewhere
in the world they recognize that
cartoons aren't just for children's
mindless entertainment
morons
what's on my mind tonight
nothing
empty mind
empty brain
no thoughts
[Music]
it's like the wind whistling through my
head i don't know if that came across
screw it
uh besides that how are you doing i'm
doing pretty good um
say hello to joni sure hi joanie
uh last band you listened to is now the
band you have to take a road trip with
who are you going with see the thing is
technically the last man i listened to
was a one-man band so i really hope i
would get along with him otherwise
that'd be really bad and that's miracle
of sound um i hadn't listened to his
stuff in a while and i was uh got into
that in the car because i had to run
errands
and that took longer than i would have
liked because stupid pharmacy decided to
fill my prescription at the next town
over
yeah
uh
pendant is lovely thank you it's just um
it's just a bit of a
bit of a geode i think
um or something like that um
it's sort of
from my kid it's one of those things
where like she
you know the the school sends kids home
with like these catalogs like get your
parents to buy stuff out of this and
it's a fundraising thing and so like i
bought this out of that catalog to
support her
um so i i like to think that she gave me
this she didn't really i paid for it and
picked it out but i did it because of
her so you know
close enough i suppose
michael anderson doyle
thank you very much for the super chat
and
oh no that's a member that's a
membership renewal you still get it
right there
uh
while i've been a member for two months
i've been a fan for longer and consider
myself blessed to have met you all
especially queen nathaniel ah
thank you i appreciate that very much
did i hear about bob saget i did i also
heard about sidney poitier
it's this this year
this year's kind of off to a
start
if i'm gonna if i'm gonna be honest
about it
wanted to ask have i watched utopia the
tv show
no i don't know what that is
so new
i don't know about religion but my
father didn't let me watch sailor moon
or rama or ranma one half when i was
five to eight that's when anime got to
uh argentina with dbz zeki
uh mikami um well like rhonda one half i
understand why that one freaks out um
religious folks and conservatives
because you know
gender stuff
but
i i have the first i think i have the
first two volumes that i need to reread
that but i'm scared to
because i'm afraid of how badly it will
have aged
i did like it when i first read it can't
imagine why
does my child call me mom no my kid
calls me dad
i'm dad i'll always be dad no matter
what
happens with my own gender journey even
if even if at some point in the future i
start identifying as a trans woman and
as purely femme and don't even go with
the with the gender neutral day pronoun
anymore i will still be dad now that's
me
that is not something that you should
take as a blanket for every gender fluid
or transitioning or transitioned parent
some of them will have their title
relative to their kids change but
speaking only for myself
i'm always going to be dad
that's the relationship that i have with
my kid and that relationship doesn't
change even as i do so
i will never be mom i will always be dad
which is also fun because it confuses
the hell out of people
i'm partial to confusing folks
the year started with betty white dying
technically 2021 ended with betty white
dying
so
you know
yeah i didn't i
i didn't grow up on shows like full
house like i watched a little
of things like um
family matters uh and like a handful of
things like very very little i didn't
grow up on those the way a lot of my
generation did
um
so while obviously my heart goes out to
his fans his family and friends i don't
have a particularly
uh tight connection to
um
to bob saget
uh did you watch the early 2000s show
the lost world nope
i hate religion i don't hate religion
i hate the way many people choose to
practice religion but i am
thankfully
old enough and have a
uh wide enough breadth of experience
that
i've had the privilege of meeting
um many people
who
are
who are religious and their religion
matters to them
deeply but they're not hurtful
they're not hateful
they're not closed minded
i think
if you are fortunate
if that has been your experience of
religiously minded people so far i hope
that you will
meet some people who
are not
that
because
some of the most
empathetic and thoughtful people i have
met
are people who actively practice some
form of faith
i always get very nervous um when
anybody especially um in the u.s
makes a blanket statement of i hate
religion or religion is is harmful
because
very often especially in the u.s
and i would say western
society in general but the us especially
when people say that
their beef is very specifically with
christianity
but they take that and they blanket
every religious practice with it i feel
like what happens is that
um
people in the us
they will
understand the specific
um harm that christianity can and has
done uh within the
within this country
and they understand possibly say islamic
extremism
especially if they happen to live
through 9 11.
and then they go well that's two
instances of me seeing religion be
terrible so all religion is terrible
like
look
faiths do not all look the same
they don't all operate the same and like
weird random tangent but it's one of the
reasons why
little moments in things like batman v
superman where there's a talking head on
the tv talking about superman he says
every religion on this planet has
has some kind of messianic figure no
they freaking don't
the ones you're thinking of do but no
no they don't and like anytime anyone
says that kind of blanket thing about
all religion just displays the ignorance
that you don't know what you're talking
about
and you have had a couple of probably
validly nasty experiences with religion
or religious people and you are just
blanketing everybody with it
and just
don't
do that
don't
whatever cosplays edward scissorhands
probably not it is too elaborate for my
taste
um is vermont a religiously minded state
or secular by u.s standards by u.s
standards vermont is fairly secular um
all things considered vermont is
by u.s standards fairly liberal
and fairly secular um
it varies you know region to region it
is uh
it can it can be weird sometimes but yet
it's not a particularly
like you're not gonna see
people in the state house
aren't gonna quote the bible as a reason
to pass a law
that's not gonna happen around here
what was my first anime show um
that's a good question uh
i'm actually not entirely sure
i suppose it depends how strictly you
want to define it
i think the first one that
like i
paid attention to
um
god it might have been blue seed
um because i like i got into anime film
before i got into anime shows
um
because i didn't i didn't have reliable
access to television growing up
um
let's see what's my favorite song from
tiktik boom i think the way the film did
therapy was incredible therapy was
really well adapted
um
as far as uh adaptationally done i would
say therapy as far as just a song to
just listen to
that's tougher um
[Music]
it it kind of goes back and forth
between
30 90 louder than words um
and johnny can't decide for the film
version um
honestly the stage version i like
uh
boho life best but they they shortened
that one up for the movie they didn't
butcher it but they did shorten it and
cut some of the bits i like
john
finals thank you very much and remember
folks yes a super chat guarantees that i
will respond to your comment or question
i don't make any promises otherwise and
it gets you a heart to show my
appreciation
thoughts on the forgotten city
it's a game that's been recommended to
me by several people that i have not
played
that's my thoughts
new type jb lee thank you very much from
the 60s to the 90s in the spidey comics
peter and his cast were allowed to organ
to have organic growth and death meant
death it's sad we can't go back to that
it
it is
but like for us to try and
roll that back
and
um
get back to that requires a fundamental
reshaping of
how
comic books are handled
like it worked for a while
because there was a stretch of time
where
aging in real time or close to real time
uh was a reasonable
thing but then as
as they properly got into the 90s and
these characters started hitting their
30th anniversaries in a lot of cases
it just stopped being particularly
viable and that's when
a lot of the 90s were not good to comics
spidey especially
freaking clone saga
what are my thoughts on disney's
gargoyles great show don't bother with
the third
season sailor moon sparked my sexual
orientation awakening i remember
catching an episode or two
of sailor moon like when i was at my
grandparents in the summer i never went
out of my way to watch it though i think
like i just caught a bit of it one time
that was about it
and i was a little too old for pokemon
when that hit
uh i want to watch tick tick boom but
vanessa hudgins takes it for me she's
she is minor like okay
i understand i do understand sometimes
some actors just
make you go
i have that with sam rockwell but like
she's playing one of the actors
not the actual people in jonathan's life
she's playing one of the actors that is
performing the shows playing one of the
people in
the um
oh god what the hell is in the in the
workshop who's just performing the songs
she's not really a character
not to sound like
too
callous about it but like get over it
mandy matiere thank you very much for
the super chat what's the first thing
you do if given a tardis
blow it up
i would not trust me with it nor would i
trust anyone else with it
so
that's probably not the answer anyone
wanted to hear
but
yeah
and unless i act super impulsively i
just blow it up
aside from how i met your mother the
only other major bob saget
um
oh
sorry that that message got retracted i
was in the middle of reading it fine
fine i won't then whatever
what did sam rockwell do sam rockwell
screwed up my favorite character in my
favorite book and completely
misunderstood the character of zafad
biebel brock's fundamentally to his core
uh to be fair so did the director and
the writers so it wasn't just him but
it was wrong
so wrong it was like it was wrong in the
most
superficial way
because
the reason that safe hud people brox is
a fascinating character is because of
what is underneath the surface level but
they just did the surface level and i'm
like that kick
drove me nuts fun fact bob saget was on
a wb show called raising dad in which he
was raising two daughters those young
ladies kat dennings and brie larson
okay then
uh
le okay i don't know how we got to the
subject of legend of the over fiend
oh boy
things have taken a turn in the chat oh
boy
[Music]
did i watch stargate
uh i never watched the show i watched
the movie i think i own the movie on dvd
actually i like the movie a lot i never
got around to the show
is my heart two sizes too small
not last i checked
i don't know if that's a pointed
question that i'm missing or what that
was
would you consider an essay on why the
x-men series veers so wildly from good
to great to garbage given it predated
spider-man i.e
the parent so well um
do you mean the movies we say the x-men
series are we talking the film series
the comic series or any number of the
multitude of tv series you're gonna have
to narrow that down
uh why do i feel john malkovich would
have made it better zaphod
i'm sorry zayfod i need to remember
that's how it's actually pronounced
um
he might have
i don't know it was made around the time
malkovich seemed to be sleeping his way
through a lot of roles so i don't know
if it actually would have
ended up better anyways
tara stuller thank you so very much if i
had a tardis i would go back in time to
find out if humanity ever makes it past
climate change and capitalism and if
they did
stay there
that's the thing if they did if they
didn't you're gonna end up real
depressed
that's uh that's a bit of a gamble
you're making
aside from when i met your mother the
only major bob saget thing i watched was
his notable appearance in the
documentary about the aristocrats joke i
saw that documentary i actually didn't
think his version was that great
there were others that i liked a lot
more than his
his was one of the grossest
sure but i actually
didn't think he i didn't think his
version was that funny
maybe it's just me legend of the
overfeeding thing is my fault well
i i i think anyone who knows legend of
the overview knows what kind of
punishment would be befitting
you having brought that up
hmm
uh
have you read the car the gargoyles
comic books nope
uh first x-men movie okay so
all right if we're talking about the
inconsistency
of the x-men film franchise
it largely comes down to there
never really was a clear person steering
the ship
so
the thing that
marvel has honestly
um
lucked out
on more than anything else
is
that
they have kevin feige
and kevin feige i'm not trying to make
him sound like some kind of amazing
creative god he's not but what he's
incredibly good at is keeping everything
organized and everybody on the same page
there really hasn't been an overseer of
these attempts at continuing franchises
or
um
you know uh expansive cinematic
universes
that has measured up to them there have
been ones who
were trying who were supposed to be
but
they either flamed out or it just has
never really worked you know kathleen
kennedy was supposed to be that for star
wars
uh she doesn't she
doesn't seem to have um managed to find
the same sweet spot and understanding uh
the material in what the um
what the fans want out of it that feige
has but the short version is
because
the um camera when do you mind with the
spam
nonsense i'd appreciate it um the with
the x-men franchise because there was no
overseer
project to project it
um
absolutely would veer wildly
because you know you had the first two
films
um you know directed by the same person
not a person we like brian singer can
go take a long walk off a short pier
but um
you know that was a fairly singular
person helming those then we get to the
third one which had to follow on from
stuff that was set up in the second but
had to be done by people who weren't
involved in that setup and clearly
wanted to do a different story so that
was a jumbled mess
you bring in a whole new sensibility
with
first class which was solid
i don't like as much as a lot of people
at least a lot of people i know
um but that ended up being solid had a
solid immediate follow-up with days of
future past but then like it felt like
the people who were still there
didn't want to be anymore like
apocalypse
is one and apocalypse and then also dark
phoenix are two of the most
soulless like everybody's just there to
cash a paycheck vibe off of those movies
of almost any major
studio project i can think of
they they really have almost nothing
uh to recommend them
and
you know and that was the point at which
um you know they were also just throwing
whatever at the wall because you know
very clearly
excellent origins wolverine which on
paper made sense because you know yeah
you're gonna spin off wolverine he's the
most popular one he works as a solo
character why not but then they made a
movie that was clearly about setting up
a ton of other stuff to do um and was a
semi incoherent mess that nobody really
liked they did a more focused version
for the sequel with him that people
liked better but it wasn't enough of a
step step up but then by the time they
got to deadpool and logan and new
mutants clearly fox
didn't know
what to do and they were just throwing
whatever they could at the wall to see
what's stuck
and they got lucky because logan stuck
deadpool stuck
and they just kept kicking new mutants
down the line because they probably
realized it wasn't good
so
there hasn't been a consistent handler
on that and it's just it the the
franchise as a whole kept changing hands
creative hands um like they had
producers carry over from film to film
but they weren't producers with
uh with a vision for what the overall
shape of the thing should be the way
kevin feige is
so
it just didn't work out very well for
for that
i saw that full fat videos like put up a
an essay today about just porting in the
existing x-men into the mcu instead of
rebooting them which i haven't watched
the video
i disagree
just on premise i'm sure he makes a good
case he usually does but like no
no it's like no
don't do that
anyways moving on welsh
welsh wrestling geeks that sounds niche
i like it you get a heart my friend
thank you very very much
now sometime has passed do you believe
series 13 of doctor who is worse than
series 11 or series 7. i am not going to
answer that because the video that is
coming out not this saturday but the
following saturday
is a re-ranking of all the series
including flux so
i'm not telling you because it would
spoil upcoming video
so instead you get a tease
thank you black cover i appreciate that
magic was good in the new mutants she
was not
oh my god no she was not
they took
they took ileana they took
colossus's little sister
and made her the [ __ ]
no
no
go sit in the corner
magic was good in new mutants good grief
anyways
thank you very much new type jb lee
the early years of married peter had
beloved arks like craven's last hunt
venom harry's death
so why do some people still dislike the
marriage anyway okay well there's a
number of things that people didn't like
about the marriage some people honestly
just held the origins of the marriage
against the marriage as a whole because
the marriage in the comics was done
super rushed it kind of came out of
nowhere really the only reason that it's
there
um is because
uh stan lee was writing the
comic strip version of spider-man which
something
that people younger than me won't
understand that is the thing that
actually exists and he was having mary
jane and peter mary in the comics so for
the sake of
uh
inter-medium continuity
they very hastily have mary jane and
peter get married in the comics i think
they were actually in an off phase of
their off-again on-again relationship
and very suddenly got back together and
got married
so
this feeling of
a very superficial
um and rushed and hasty and ill-advised
way to handle their marriage is
something that a lot of fans held
against the marriage no matter what
storylines came out of it later which i
think was very petty
uh because i like them i like peter
married i like peter having at least a
sem my stable
home life as opposed to a complete
disaster
home life so i liked married peter
but a lot of fans particularly fans who
had been around prior to them getting
married did not like it at all and then
you have the both writers and fans who
think for some reason that a
married and functioning couple is boring
these people are boring that's my
opinion on that
will you perhaps be checking your p.o
box in say three or four days time
i can be
i can check it uh later in the week
easily enough
the racism of magic and new mutants was
a huge wtf yeah that's kind of what i
was getting at
uh
my partner just turned 30. do you have
any advice for her she says it feels
weird wait till you're about to turn 40.
um no like 30 does feel weird though
30 is
30 is the age where
you feel like you have no business
feeling like a kid anymore where you
feel like
i'm i'm now a proper adult or i'm
supposed to be
and so people tend to either feel weird
or
feel that there's something wrong with
them for however big the disparity is
between
how they
still feel young but they're so they
believe they're supposed to be an adult
and that disconnect is
not fun
you'll roll with it you'll get the hang
of it this too shall pass
but yeah no it's it's an awkward
transition
while we're talking spider-man have you
ever played the spider-man 2 ps2 game i
have not i know yahtzee crowshaw swears
by it but i have not what type of stone
are you wearing i believe it is a geode
i am not a 100 sure i'd have to go like
check my old purchase on that thoughts
on dexter well keep in mind i have not
seen the revival of the show my thoughts
on the original dexter was
that it had
seven seasons of good to great
television best season is season two
season seven is underrated as a season
five for that matter everyone swears by
season four it's good it's not the best
season two
is the best season of that and season
eight
is such a crash and burn
holy crap
holy crap
what's the weirdest thing a fan has ever
sent you
um hmm
i
see i i don't want to use weird because
i feel like there is uh an inherent
negative connotation to weird there are
some unusual things i've been sent
i got sent a whole bunch
of uh
canned pickles like single pickles in
cans
um that like in theory you you put in
the glove compartment
uh of your car for a driving snack i
sent a whole bunch of those
uh that was interesting i have and it's
it's
over there
somebody made for me i think it's
crocheted or it's it's either crocheted
or knit i like i'm really bad
at um sorting out somebody like made a
little doll
of me
and you know i've had fan art made which
i also love but the fact that somebody
actually you know made that and sent it
to me it's like oh my gosh
um and there's also
um there's also this multicolored dragon
this rainbow dragon which is a custom
piece that somebody made and sent to me
like these are these are unusual
non-standard things but it's like it's
the things that either i didn't know
that was a thing that existed at all or
that people made
that they sent me i'm like
that
you put time it like
the people put thought into things they
send me all the time and i absolutely
appreciate that but some of the things i
get i'm like you put
you put amounts of time into that i
don't even know if i could harness for
myself and you did it for another person
you did it for me
now that's not to make anyone feel like
oh i didn't make you something by hand
to send you oh you must not think about
no no look
i feel the appreciation and
the love
in packages that are sent to me
what you put in
i feel it when i open them up
so
even if
you say if something you've sent to me
is a pre-bought item if it's heck of it
second hand
i will still appreciate the heck out of
it
turning red will be on disney plus
instead of theaters that's a question
mark at the end of that are you asking
me or are you telling me sorry to ask
this again but could you answer the
question someone commented on my video i
assumed it's intended in good faith i
don't have a twitter by the way um
i'm missing something black cover i'm
not
someone
i
i don't know what the
question you're referring to
is
i'm lost on that one
uh if he if he can catch me up i'll try
and help
something i will always find funny is
captain america's steve rogers isn't
even american biologically speaking he's
high rich no i'm not kidding
that is entertaining i'm michael
anderson doyle thank you very much for
the super chat here i am about to turn
50 and thinking how weird it is that i'm
turning 50. it feels weird to be turning
40. so like yeah no if i feel like like
here's the thing to keep in mind decades
don't actually mean anything
the human brain is is uh
wired
to like to go with the factors of 10 for
most of us uh so we ascribe meaning to
things that uh fit into tens but like
decades don't have meaning
it's an arbitrary amount of time
they're not special
neither are years for that matter
you know collectively
the overall progression of time matters
but like
oh it's the end of one year the start of
it like new year's
it doesn't mean anything
we made it up does not actually have
special significance that's not to say
that it can't mean something to you
but like i'm talking in the in the
vastness of
the universe
it's just one day turning into another
and when enough of them do that we
arbitrarily call it a year
and when enough of those happen we
arbitrarily call it a decade
they're not as meaningful as we ascribe
to them
uh what i love about
uh amy and rory is they refute the idea
that married couples are boring i i'd
agree with that any ideas how to spend a
certain someone's 25th birthday i don't
know i haven't done anything interesting
for my birthday in an embarrassingly
long amount of time
that was supposed to change in 2020 hmm
we're probably gonna be coming up on my
third birthday where it's not gonna be
safe for me to even try and do anything
of note
uh do you think people say that season
four is the best entirely because of
john lithgow i think that's a big part
of it i think a lot of people were
bowled over by the ending of it for
dexter
i suspect those are those are parts of
it
uh
favorite pie to eat around the holidays
apple mincemeat pumpkin i'm partial to
apple
i always kind of have been
although um i have uh
uh
i have a tradition of of
having um
chocolate cream pie at thanksgiving
so
spoiled that way
so a few who
so few who questions so thoughts on the
sea devil design and the idea of
bringing them back i love the idea
bringing them back i think the design is
very true to the original i love the sea
devils so i'm
eager
we'll see if it works
uh hey at least you'll never go 100
hungry when you're driving if you've got
a pickle
why don't you like waffles i don't like
um
particularly
sweet um
breakfasts
uh
like they they're
they they're cloying to me at this point
pancakes waffles french toast and a lot
of this stuff is pretty rich like more
than one and
my body's just like what are you doing
dude first thing in the morning what are
you doing
have you ever seen any of the shows
produced by vivian medrano will you ever
make a video on them if
not they're worth watching
i don't know what shows have been
produced
by vivian medrano so you'd have to cite
me examples because i don't know
uh the video was a clip of you talking
about the bbc oh okay
um i gotta all right
um
is is is your username in this that you
use for chat is that your your youtube
channel where
um
this all went down because i can i can
check that uh
later tonight um if your youtube channel
is named something different you need to
you need to tell me
uh watch don't look up uh because of
your review i thought it was great it's
a must-see and it's 150 accurate to how
a human race would react tonight i'm
watching encanto i'm glad you liked it i
didn't particularly but uh i do think
encounters a better movie regardless
uh
let's see
uh i might have said this before but do
you expect rtd to pull the rug out from
under our feet and make season 14
and going forward something completely
different than his first era
i mean
i don't expect it to be a rehash of what
he did with his previous time but i also
don't think he's the kind of person to
do something just because people aren't
expecting it he doesn't strike me as
someone
who's gonna just pull the ooh you didn't
see that coming did you oh i gotcha like
i don't think he's that kind of creator
at least i hope not
because that's how you get game of
thrones season eight and nobody wants
game of thrones season eight i had asked
you about it in an early stream told me
to remind you over twitter but i don't
have a twitter ah okay well just just
let me know in chat if
that is
the name of your youtube channel and i
will try and set a reminder uh to
clarify what i mean is fans of the show
who are like now things will go back to
normal with rtd again rtd being like
nope here's something drastically
different
i think he's gonna do whatever he feels
like doing and i personally am of the
opinion that it will probably be
something different from what he did
before because he doesn't strike me as
the kind of person who wants to keep
repeating the same stuff over and over
again
uh
yes it's this username okay great
awesome new type jb lee thank you very
much for the super chat how come no
spidey adaptation captured the sarcastic
edge of ditko air spidey with pete
trading harsh quips
uh with flash
is the remita era more popular
there's some
weirdness
in the ditco
era there's some
there's there's a nastiness to
especially the latter end
of ditko's run
that i for one
don't love i don't know other fans
assessments
of it
um
nerdsync did a very
very well done video recently on ditko
um and ditko's work on spider-man and
specific but also other stuff uh about
him and how that kind of influenced his
work on spider-man in particular but
also in general um
yeah i think by by the time he finished
on spider-man some of ditko's
less pleasant
uh aspects were bleeding into the
character in ways that at least i don't
particularly care for
over the years i've started to hate a
word i don't like to use
is that people only look at superman and
see the powers and say characters like
homeland or as a superman proxy
yeah
see well i can't speak to homelanders
specifically because i don't watch the
boys
um
so i think part of it is is there
people are very haphazard with their
words
people will use proxy when maybe a
better term would be
deconstruction or inversion or parody
of the idea of superman you're right a
lot of people especially people who
don't actually read superman but know
just enough about him seem to not
understand the character
very much
um and because a lot of the recurring
criticisms of superman as a character
feel like they come from people who
don't understand why he works and they
come in with an assumption that like no
superman is a bad character because x
i'm like but that's not even
true
all he does is punch things no
no he doesn't his disguise is stupid no
his disguise works it's been addressed
phenomenally in some stories and
explained incredibly well
uh
but and you know even people who will go
on and on and on like freaking tarantino
with kill bill
uh vol 2 don't understand superman and
it's weird because he's not that
complicated
i don't know why he's so hard to get for
some people
uh question mark regarding turning red
being on disney plus was a typo oh okay
i mean it makes sense a lot of the
theaters are shutting down again
are you planning to watch the naomi show
it looks interesting i don't know what
that is
uh i'm sorry to tell you this
uh if
uh if you don't but did you know
someone did a live stream about one of
your gatekeeping videos
i did not know that
do i want
to know
who
did that
like
some of those videos are real old i'm
not sure i i'm not sure how much i'd
stand by some of them now some of them
are like two three years old
um unless it's one of the newer ones
but
i don't know
i read the title uh and yo is it
bi-weekly already
uh it's the live stream has always been
bi-weekly
oh is it bye week already ah no
every week's bi-week
has been hotel and hell of a boss oh
i've heard of those i think i tried
uh
watching husband hotel and it was a
little too chaotic a little too hyper
for my tastes
um
[Music]
i i didn't try past that
would it be funny if joe pesci and
marisa tomay
showed up in cobra kai as daniel's
cousin
and his wife
yes
yes it would uh it won't happen but yes
yes that would be funny
have i seen tangled the series nope
heard a couple of the songs from but
they're pretty good
just popping in to say hi in the middle
of filming at the moment well good to
see you lewis
oh
john sneaky bug bugger seven foot frame
rats along his back when he calls your
name it all fades to black i'm not gonna
keep going because i don't want the
thing to get flagged
ah
we don't talk about bruno
i watched the first season of american
gods and liked it but i heard season two
isn't worth it it's not
i didn't even see season three i heard
it's better than season two but that is
not
saying
a lot
let's see here
on the subject of rtd i finally watched
it's a sin so good but so sad yep
yep the naomi show is a dcu character
one of the less known
okay
uh
i just found out that the actress who
plays elvira came out of the closet last
year i should not have been surprised as
i was like that was one of those
instances where it's like
i actually found myself thinking
was she not out before
are we sure
really
that was really great
to be fair to tarantino that is a
villain's take on superman to say more
about the characters it says more about
the character's skew perspective
fair but at the same time like tarantino
does kind of have his head up his own
ass
i do still like kill bill
uh naomi is uh an eva
uh
eva duvernay dc television show
premieres today
okay
i'd like i have not heard of this thing
oh bookworm of the fandoms thank you
very much you get a heart i appreciate
that greatly and kanto's my new favorite
animated movie uh first one a long time
that i'm interacting with the fan base i
forget if you answered this in your
review but did you have a favorite song
and or character when you watched it
um
[Music]
there's there's some really good songs
uh
it um
i think
surface pressure and louisa as a result
are probably both my favorite
um
partially because like i feel like that
song
um
exemplifies
a lot of what's really going on like
there are other songs that do as well
but there's something about
how hard that one hits home with the
idea of
what
these people are sacrificing for the eye
for the notion of helping their family
and what they're losing of themselves
and
are continuing to move forward
regardless and plus you know
i'm not gonna go as far as say i have a
type i actually don't i find a wide
spectrum of
body shapes and types to be attractive
but like between this and scorpio i
definitely have to cop to the fact that
um
muscled women who could break me in half
there's there's a there's a thing
there's a thing there
that's
yeah wouldn't recommend watching the
live stream it's just biggest trying to
justify the bigotry i just didn't know
whether to tell you or not make you sad
please forgive ah
whatever i'm actually the only thing is
i i'm
uh surprised
that
that stuff doesn't happen more than it
does i honestly think the only reason it
doesn't happen to me more um is because
i think a lot of bigots are actually
confused by me
and they're like they're too confused to
come at me
not that like it gives me an immunity
but
you know you pay attention for more than
10 seconds and you'll quickly realize
the standards of you'll never be a woman
and that's actually doesn't apply
because i don't claim to be in the first
place and then they just don't know what
to do
so i i think i puzzle
uh enough of them that they're like i'm
gonna find it i'm gonna find an easier
more straightforward target
um
the discord yes thank you carowind uh
just give me one moment i'll get right
to that john vinyls once again thank you
i greatly appreciate that ever read the
magical realist literature that helped
inspire encanto
no i have not
but i'm just gonna pop over to the
discord
real quick reminder that that is the
other place where you can post and it is
guaranteed that i will read your comment
or question because it is a patreon
exclusive perk patreon.com
councilofgeeks
um
are the live streams getting later by a
half hour no not as a regular thing um i
had i was interviewing somebody uh for
an upcoming video project
pretty much immediately before and i
wanted to have a buffer i ended up not
needing as much of a buffer as i gave
myself but like i need to learn to build
in
uh time buffers more than i currently do
um
because that's
i
i think i do think it's an adhd thing
that i have a tendency to just fill the
time
um as much as possible but that means
that the instant something
goes longer than i expected to or starts
later than i expected to there's a
domino effect
so i'm trying to get better about
setting
padding
uh and that's that's the only one i got
in there cool popping back in
uh
you could do a tick tock with a virus
no this is a bust quote just saying
oh
wonderfully terrible
humor
she's good stuff
i cast a transgender actress as madame
marble in oh sorry they cast a
transgender actress as madame marble and
wicked her name is alexandra billings
she's the first transactress
that
they cast
um
sorry miss wicked wolf i don't mean to
be a pedantic jackass but i do i i am
correcting you because casted
that's not no they cast
he was cash she was cast they cast this
person
it's never casted
um
have you heard that guillermo del toro
is producing an animated version of
pinocchio is it going animated now i
know he'd been working on a version of
pinocchio like for ages i knew that was
a thing
i didn't i don't think i'd heard that it
was going to be
um animated now
let's see
speaking of superman i've read that uh
the john kent book with that image and
it's not bad the whole story is john
stretching himself super thin to try and
make his dad proud
yeah i'd like theirs they've been doing
some
they've been doing a lot of stuff with
superman lately that i'm like that
sounds interesting i'm still not going
to read it but on paper at least one
thing i would give encounter credit for
is they didn't do the whole sky high
thing with maribel i was so relieved
actually after we watched it for the
first time i talked to my kid about that
about how i was dreading that the thing
at the end would be and now she gets a
gift out of no more like no it's so much
more interesting and actually means
something if she doesn't have a gift but
she still matters
like i got sky high
pissed me off
so much
so goddamn much that movie pissed me off
it didn't understand its own
[ __ ] point
don't worry about those idiots live
stream worry about my video where i
debunk your book and claim that you hate
england
joel's already working on the thumbnail
i mean you do realize with how english
my lineage is
you're accusing me of a form of
self-loathing i hope you realize that
uh my partner sounds like you she will
pad time like mad even though
uh we have one focused thing to go yeah
welsh wrestling geeks uh thank you very
much greatly appreciated i live in
cardiff and children of earth was filmed
10 minutes away from where i live and
i'm still scared to go near the areas
i'm in my 20s honestly
given that series and like how it lands
i
don't blame you
like that thing hits
like a wrecking ball it's not gentle
are there any comic book story lines
you'd like to see in the mcu but only if
they spread it over multiple phases like
the infinity saga
no
because the thing is in comic books the
big crossover
um
spam you know universe spanning stories
aren't the
ones that interest me the most
generally speaking
um so no
no i don't
i don't think i'll tell you what one i
never want to see
like i never wanted like and i know
technically they did apocalypse in the
fox x
but i never want to see freaking age of
apocalypse
and i honestly i never want to see any
of cable's bs
translated you want to bring in the
character the way deadpool 2 did it fine
but like his actual story lines like
that senator
convoluted god damn
garbage
do i like the scream movies i like the
first one i've only seen the first three
um
i like the first one
the other two are
sac one's trying third one isn't very
much
all english people hate themselves a
true english person would know that
touche
that's french
did i get your english blood up
uh
are there any films that require you to
have a box of tissues
at the ready i'm not usually a crier but
uh akira malta story get me every time
um i mean honestly i did a video a
couple years ago about movies that make
me cry uh every time so i i'm gonna
default to that
um
yeah that there are there are some
and
yeah
sometimes that stuff
really
really hits there was something
what the hell was it
there was something that
for some reason i found myself watching
like i'm just gonna check out this scene
again see if it hits as hard as it did
last time i watched it and it did and i
was an absolute disaster i can't
remember what that was now
ah that's going to bug me
uh ever heard of the author chuck tingle
oh yes
i'm familiar with chuck tingle i've not
read any of chuck tingle's work but i am
familiar have i seen hilda i have my kid
and i watched that together we needed to
see the new movie
um sorry i keep pestering you um
but do you know good omens yes i've read
the book i've seen the show both good
uh
i know soul hit you pretty hard it did
yep it did only time i've ever seen you
tear up on camera um there's a few other
videos where i do that was one
um
talking about
tracy's story which was uh
an episode of the accused i got
commissioned to review i
i choked up towards the end of that one
uh it's happened a couple times
with a few things
but uh
anyways i think it's yeah
yep it's about time to wrap it up i have
kids no i have kid singular i have one
kid
i'm no i don't have kids plural i have
one kid
uh
is that is that not common knowledge
i thought i'd have been liberal enough
with that detail that it was well known
at this point not that i'm judging you
for not knowing that it's fine it
comes up sporadically she does not show
up on camera
um
so
you know
it's fine
uh do you watch a discovery of witches
nope
like there's so much stuff that like
the thing is most things that like have
just started are just coming out or like
oh this came out in last year have you
seen this odds are if you if i have not
made a video on it i probably didn't
watch it
and not not necessarily because i was
like not watching that but just like
there's too much stuff
there's way too much damn stuff
david dixon ford free ford prefect in
the hitchhiker's tv series was a better
fifth doctor than the fifth doctor
well you know my
feelings on
peter davison are documented he's a
lovely fellow in person though i did
meet him uh
2020 california one
before every everything shut down yes
thank you heroine for the reminder
so
uh tomorrow
10 30 a.m eastern
um i will be continuing to play
final fantasy vii
remake
uh
and working my way through that and so
anyone who wants to
watch me there can do so
twitch.tv slash council of geeks
hope to see folks there
um
other than that
i'll be streaming again on friday and
then new video here on saturday and
there's links in the description for all
the other nonsense i do be it
twitch be it twitter be it instagram
which i barely do anymore
uh yeah most stuff you'll find links to
not everything but most of it
what is my most anticipated movie of the
year not gonna tell you that because
that is this coming saturday's video is
the stuff that i think looks exciting
this year anyways thank you all greatly
appreciate it
thank you for spending time with me and
take care of yourselves and i want you
to remember that
you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings so until next time this council
is adjourned
we're coming